welcome everyone i'm maggie pockella
from the genetic sciences division
at thermo fisher scientific thank you so
much for joining us today for our
presentation titled contribution of
chromosomal microarrays and precision
medicine
for the clinical laboratory it's my
pleasure to introduce you to dr lea
menair who's a division director of
molecular pathology at cytogenetics
within the department of pathology at
hartford hospital hartford healthcare
doctor mener and her team provide
molecular pathology and cytogenetics
testing services for the entire hartford
healthcare hospital system
and the connecticut children's medical
center
she has designed developed and
clinically validated
numerous molecular cytogenetic assays
and has extensive expertise in test
design
interpretation and reporting for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during
this presentation we encourage you to
submit your
q a in the q a box our speaker will
address your questions following this
presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational
and offers free continuing education
credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of this presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
for now we'll turn this over to dr miner
thank you so much
hi so this is my title
and these are my disclosures
so uh microarray analysis
detects copy number changes
which have emerged as a component of
precision medicine
copy number changes can also represent a
responsive biomarker to
targeted therapy copy number changes
have also been
implicated as biomarkers in therapy
resistance
they are also a prognostic value
and they can be also used to distinguish
between
benign versus malignant tumors
so the microarrays are a an important
part
of the an integral part of the molecular
pathology
and cytogenetics lab menu at hartford
healthcare
so microarray testing has applications
in both solid tumors and hematopathology
we offer the arrays as standalone assays
and also
as part of the workup of a certain tumor
also we offer that as a reflex to
a karyotype or fish testing
in this presentation i'll be describing
the uses of microarray
in our clinical lab that has extensive
test menu and explaining how it fits
among this the the services that we
currently provide
so the molecular pathology and
cytogenetic
cytogenomics labs at hartford healthcare
provide
full service service provide full
services in molecular pathology
and at this time we continue to offer
standalone assays
in virath egfr and keras we continue to
maintain those
uh for the sake of a quick turnaround
time we also have applications
uh in sanger sequencing as well as
fragment analysis
which we use uh the uh for we use the
api system for these
um in the past few years we have moved
heavily towards next generation
sequencing
and at this time for solid tumors we
carry
three njs panels uh we have a 99 gene
dns
dna based panel that we custom designed
and we offered this in combination with
another custom designed
64 gene rna based fusion panel
we offer those combined in combination
for a lung colorectal breast thyroid
endometrial ovarian and other cancers
for the sarcoma similarly we use the 99
gene
dna based panel along with an
off-the-shelf 26
gene rna based fusion
panel specifically targeting sarcomas
this was off the shelf from archer df
um the molecular pathology labs at
hartford healthcare also provide full
service
test menu for hemato pathology
and among an ex among an extensive menu
of standalone
assays that we offered in hindpath we
also offered
we carry a 75 gene a dna myeloid
panel njs panel we also have a custom
designed 170 gene dna based
lymphoid panel and as well as a 205
genes
rna-based fusion panel with applications
in myeloid and lymphoid malignancies
um the labs are also a full service
cytogenetics labs
we offer karyotyping that and
applied to multiple sample types we have
an
extensive fish menu with fish probes
used on peripheral blood bone marrow
lymph nodes cell pellets ffpes and
others
microarray testing has also been
validated to run
a peripheral blood bone metal ffpes
products of conception lymph nodes and
other specimen types
i'm going to start with a well-known
biomarker that is of diagnostic and
therapeutic importance uh it's the
kiaa1549 birac
fusion and the this fusion is frequently
associated with cerebellar midline
pilocytic astrocytoma which is a subtype
of pediatric low-grade
gliomas and we see those in 60 to 80
percent of
this tissue type these are activating
and that activate the map kinase pathway
patients with this fusion are
responsible for treatment with suraponym
which is a multi-kinase inhibitor these
tumors are resistant to them uracil
and the graphene this fusion
uh can is also responsive uh
to a number of compounds that are
currently in clinical trials
and also it's responsive to mac
inhibitors these
are recent uh mac inhibitors
called imatinib and beanie methane
combinatorial therapies uh of uh
traumatic
or been imagining in combination with
the m2
inhibitor evarolimus have been shown
effective
uh for the ki aa1549 b
rap newton brain tumors
uh with this fusion uh there's a
duplication
associated uh with this uh fusion
and it has been our only marker
for the longest time uh for us to be
able
to characterize and to select those
patients that have this
uh fusion uh translocation uh
for uh targeted therapies um
so this is the duplication as it's
visualized by the array
uh it's a one point nine to two mega
base fusion
that maps to the uh the long arm of
chromosome seven
uh band q three four and
this is how it's visualized uh by the
array
when you zoom in uh showing the the
characteristic duplication
and this is a zoom in at the duplication
and then showing
where the ki uh aa1549
and the vrav are located at the ends of
this duplication
and this is how it's visualized using
diffusion
uh assay that we currently also we use
uh in combination with this with array
um the the arrays are also used
as to identify certain diagnostic
genomic profiles so for for example
burkitt-like lymphoma that has a
characteristic 11q aberrations
this is a new entity of the germinal
center derived highly aggressive b-cell
lymphoma
that has recently been recognized in the
whole of 2017 classification
this diagnosis uh as recommended by the
whole should be considered in patients
with high-grade b-cell non-hodgkin's
lymphomas
that lack the c-mec gene rearrangement
um this is a a
figure this is actually our figure
that is showing the morphology and the
stains
and then as well as the character
characteristic
genomic profile it's a characteristic
rearrangement or duplication and
terminal deletion
in chromosome 11. uh
this this is our figure as i mentioned
it was selected
for the journal cover uh from a
an article that we submitted uh the
microarray analysis
of those lymph nodes should be done on
the involved lymphoids
and uh that the these tumors they show a
proximal gain of 11 q
followed by a terminal deletion and this
is pretty characteristic of this
category and this is actually a more
recent
case this is a 65 years old male
that presented with severe abdominal
pain and rapidly growing mesenteric
masses and multi lymphadenopathy
by flow the abnormal cells were positive
for cd 19
20 and 10 and were lambda restricted
by fish uh we found out that the patient
that the lymph node or the tumor cells
were negative for dcl2 bcl-6
and c-mec the microarray showed
the proximal gain of 11q
and then along with the terminal
deletion of 11q
and so this case was characterized as or
like diagnosed as burkett like lymphoma
another application of the microarrays
is the identification of a
certain of certain variations
such as the amplification of fgfr1 gene
um is a marker of uh of
targeted therapy or therapy resistance
in general
so this is an example this is a case 81
years old male 1
that had a history of diabetes mellitus
copd and the history was diagnosed
with not small cell lung cancer in july
2017
but then recently uh presented with the
lung mass
and the liver mass and then was
diagnosed
uh was found to have metastatic
non-small cell lung cancer
and then fgfr1 gene amplification
so this is as i mentioned is a mechanism
of uh
treatment resistance uh this is the
genomic profile by the array of the case
and uh this is the chromosome number
eight
uh showing the where fgfr1 amplification
was identified
and um the the array recorded or
identified 32 copies of the fgfr1 gene
and this correlated with the finding by
njs
which identified a 16-fold change
a copy number change which corresponds
to
32 copies in total
we also use the arrays in
certain in difficult certain areas or
equivocal scenarios with the her2 breast
cancer
this is the her2 is the human epidermal
growth factor receptor 2
is a valuable prognostic and predictive
biomarker in breast cancer
and the accurate assessment of her2
status is essential in selecting the
patients with invasive breast cancer
who will likely response for her to
targeted therapies so we use in our lab
we use the fda approved path vision
um abba to the fish assay and
we and then we reflect that to
unequivocal
uh cases by ihc having uh
plus 2 by ihc and then according to the
new guidelines by the asco cap of 2018
these were device guidelines that uh
determined that her2
the ratio offered two sip 17 of to
equal to two or higher is considered as
amplified
so so this is an example of such a case
where the arrays helped us
uh determine and then be confident about
the call so this is a 74 years old
female
the surgical pathology report
looked at a left breast mass
and and then it was diagnosed as an
invasive ductal carcinoma hydrate
ihc her2 was equivocal plus 12
uh plus two with heterogeneity and then
the fish her2
uh was applied and then we had a herd to
septual ratio of 2.67
so we were a little bit uh un
at uh we were kind of
worried about calling this amplified
because it's pretty much
it's very close to the cut-off so we
ended up running it
on the array and uh this was the
the genomic profile uh identified by the
array so there were multiple copy number
changes
and then this is where the her2 resides
on the long arm of chromosome 17
and this is where the her2 is and then
the array identified a copy number of
three and then we were confident at this
time
to call it as her2 amplified
uh this is another case along the
adenocarcinoma
this is a 58 years old female diagnosed
in 2018 with egfr mutant lung
adenocarcinoma
and then at that time the patient was
found to have an activating mutation in
the egfr
the l858r so the patient was started on
tarsiva
imatinib a fatima and then
the patient continued to respond until
recently
very recently deficient progress with
brain metastasis
and tumor resection was performed and
we we were given um sections from the
tumor
the a tumor cellularity of 70 was given
to us
so we ran the as part of the workup
a microarray was ordered we ran the
array and as you can see there
is a quite a bit of copy number gains
and among the copy number gain there was
an
a number gain of meth the med gene
that maps to the long arm of chromosome
7
and as you can see by the array identity
the array identified the copy number 10
and then similarly the copy number again
was
identified by ngs and uh 14 copies of
the met
uh were were detected and
met gene amplification uh
is a um is a method or is
a mechanism of targeted therapy
resistance
and and then this is pretty much
what we've done for the case um we also
use um the arrays to rule out
a hidden hypodiploidy um that is
a high risk finding in acutely
lymphoblastic leukemia and according to
the cog
uh we are um it's it's indicated that
you run
an array uh to rule out
and or duplication or hypodeploidy
whenever you see
tetra swami's or multiple
chromosomes that are tetrasomic but this
is a case that was that had
uh trisomy was near a trisome a near
triploidy and then however when we ran
the array it identified a hypodiploidy
which is a high-risk um finding
in velimoblastic leukemia so this is an
example
another example how we utilize the
arrays in our lab
we also use it to determine
tumor-relatedness um this is
an example of a 38 years old male
that was recently diagnosed with
testicular carcinoma
uh and then very recently uh
was uh uh found to have a liver mass
uh that was the histology was in the
neuroendocrine tumor and there was
um a question if this was a metastasis
from the prostate tumor
so the array was ordered and as you can
see
it shows that there is marked difference
from the
testicle and then as a result uh
it was determined that this is a newly
arising
uh tumor independent from the tumor that
was
uh seen in the in the testicle
um it's also used the arrays are also
used to determine
a risk evaluate for risk evaluation
and for tumor staging this is an example
of a womb's tumor metastatic
nephroblastoma
the the array was performed on a lung
legion and then this is the deletion
that is associated with wilms tumor
where there is a deletion of 15 megabase
of including or of the region of the
wt1 gene and then the array also
identified a duplication
of one cube and lots of petros identity
of one p
although the histology uh have
determined that this is favorable
histology
the array is indicated for such cases
and then the association and then um
and then this is an article that shows
and and that how
uh this finding of duplication of one
queue
along with lots of heterozygosity of the
one p
um uh is considered as an inferior
uh survival marker and it changes the
uh the prognostication of this case
so uh this is another um
indication or another application of the
arrays
um other additional scenarios where
microarray testing is applicable
we apply uh microarrays to all brain
tumors
and the for example the things that we
look for
in glioblastoma multiforme
egfr gene amplification is clinically
relevant
and is a targetable finding
we also look use the arrays on
liposarcoma versus lipoma we look for
mdm2 gene amplifications and other
findings
with pocs we routinely apply
the arrays whenever the cytogenetics
routine cycle genetics
yields a 46xx
this is an example of a poc that gave a
46xx bikery type
however when we performed the array uh
there was
a uh there was a trisomy again of
chromosome 14 trisomy 14 and then
because of the maternal
cell contamination uh there was if the
the
the baby or the poc is male but then
because of the maternal cell
contamination
uh the array gave this uh profile
and you can when looking at the
uh at the tracks you can identify
primarism
all over the genome and then
last and not least i want to thank the
the
team of people who work uh relentlessly
on bringing this line of testing to our
patients
oncologists and pathologists and thank
you for your attention
thank you so much leila i really
appreciate that
we have a couple of minutes to take some
questions
um we're gonna move into our q a portion
of this
as a reminder you can submit your
questions via the q
a box and any that we don't get to today
we will answer on email
so dr mania the first question i have
here is about
ngs and microarrays and using them so
how do you decide when to use ngs and
when to use microarray
well um the the decision
is made uh partly by
the oncologists and the pathologists and
partly by us depending on
what what uh on which other tests have
been performed on the case
for example if we see a fish result
and then so that's when we determine
that maybe we need an array on the case
um
as i showed you in the pocs whenever
we have a 46xx we go right away ahead
because the requisition form say
to b reflects to array should a 46xx is
found uh with brain tumors uh
it's uh part of the workup whenever we
get
a a a brain
case uh it's part of the workup it's
right away we done
the the array um in case of lipoma
and liposarcoma mdm2 gene amplification
um sometimes we run the fish but then
other times the oncologist
and the pathologist would like to see an
array
to see if there are extensive structural
rearrangements or other things going on
thank you um so i have another question
here
um and you mentioned fish so in regards
to that have you seen any discrepancies
between fish her2 and microarray testing
um whenever the the uh
the tumor cellularity is adequate
and then we try to correct for the tumor
cellularity
on the array and on ngs there has not
been any discrepancies
as a matter of fact uh the the uh
array has been very useful uh in helping
us
decide on those at the cutoff
uh cases when you feel unease of calling
it
amplified or non-amplified uh by fish
and especially when there is tumor
heterogeneity when there are like
certain
areas that are that appear to be a
little bit like
high but then this has been like a very
useful
tool thank you
um so we have one more maybe two more
times for about two more questions i
think
uh so i have one here about one of the
cases you talked about do you always run
a microarray for cmic bcl2
and bcl6 negative b cell lyphoma
lymphoma um we
and now um uh once
the beca if it is an aggressive
um uh lymphoma uh diffuse large b cell
lymphoma
and then we get negative by
uh cmec bcl2 um
bcl6 and irf4 so we now this is
in our workflow we run the the array
to rule out a vertical flight
okay great thank you and we have for one
more question
so this one has come in and it says what
is the minimum
tumor cellularity that you accept for
microarray testing
um because the tumor cellularity
is an estimate it's not
always accurate so uh
sometimes um we we can run the array at
10
10 to 15 we prefer the 20
but then because of the variation
in the estimated tumor cellularity uh
we we can run it at ten percent
thank you so much um so it looks like
that all is all we have time for today
excuse me
as a reminder though again any questions
that you submitted today for dr miner
that we're not answer we will address
via email so please keep those coming in
and thank you
thank you again dr monar for joining me
and thank you for the audience for all
your participation
uh don't miss out on all the other
valuable presentations
around this virtual event you can visit
the agenda tab
in the auditorium for a full listing and
to learn more about our chromosomal
microarrays for oncology applications
please visit the microarray analysis
booth in the exhibit hall
or you can click on the red request more
information button throughout our
virtual event
lastly this presentation that you saw
today will be available on demand
on lab routes through september 30th
2021
please go ahead and share it with any
colleagues that might be interested
thanks again so much dr miner and thank
you for the audience for your
participation
have a great day you're welcome
thank you for having me